hey guys so we just got you the feathery
land wildlife start here in Sydney
Australia and this is one of the only
places where you can actually touch the
animals and there's koala bears I
believe there's some kangaroos and some
other sort of things so we're gonna
check it out I don't think you can touch
those things I think they get shots
just chase him away
no come here
his name's Noah I saw on the side is
he's a male for in 2009 typical 2009
baby Noah Noah he's like go away
what are you we get to go in get a
picture of the closer he saw
don't you know wild chicken here in the
wild I think he might be rolling it into
the crevasse so we had such a fun time
at the little Wilderness Park let me
know what your favorite animal is leave
me a comment below and I'll see you guys
in the next video